here we are on earth
when you travel far enough away from
Earth One Thing becomes clear
this planet alone in the cosmos is the
place where people live
you probably know that voice but maybe
not the person who wrote the words Meryl
Streep narrates the Apple TV adaptation
of Oliver jeffer's book here we are
notes for living on planet Earth it's
just one offering by the artist from
Northern Ireland who sold more than 14
million books worldwide in his new book
meanwhile back on Earth Jeffers takes
readers on a ride through space and
explains some complicated topics for
young audiences Nikki Batiste met
Jeffers in his Brooklyn New York Studio
to talk about his Unique Style which has
made him a favorite among kids and kids
at heart I think a lot of people may not
know your name but they know this
handwriting yeah Oliver Jeffers is a
name you might not recognize when I was
doing book tours and I would stand up
there and kids didn't care who I was
until I started drawing them like oh
that guy but that guy's work is sitting
on kids bookshelves and in bookstores
around the world including Brooklyn's
books are magic where Jeffers bumped
into a young fan were you a big reader
when you were growing up uh no I was not
but I was much more interested in
playing football in the street or
digging holes or drawing pictures the
author's childhood love of illustration
Drew him to the art world he exhibited
works in Northern Ireland and Australia
when his career took a chance turn the
art that I was making was paintings they
were all you know single images very
narrative based rather than telling the
beginning or the middle or the end of a
story each one of these paintings was
one of those three and then I had this
one idea that
rather than have it as a series of
paintings I recognize this is going to
be better as a book
and maybe a picture book and that became
hard to catch a star from how to catch a
star came 20 other picture books
including the New York Times bestseller
here we are it was his first written
after the birth of his first child
Harlan until I had kids the books were
really just me kind of entertaining
myself just telling good stories that I
wouldn't would have wanted to hear as a
child and and thankfully it just so
happened that my sense of humor
resonates with a lot of five-year-olds
walking around the face of Earth but
when we had a kid this filter shift
happened where it's like wait a minute I
have to explain everything to you his
new book meanwhile back on Earth was
inspired by jeffer's own experience
growing up in Northern Ireland the story
is told through the lens of a family
road trip through space it was a way for
Jeffers to explain topics like climate
change and global conflict
the idea was born out of his art
installation in the United Kingdom our
place in space it's an over five mile
long scale model of the solar system it
feels like meanwhile back on Earth is
fun for kids looking at space but really
A History lesson for adults yes it's a
history lesson for adults but it's also
a comment on the environment in which we
live you can throw a dart back through
time in history and wherever it lands
pretty much you're going to find some
all-consuming battle that took place and
humans fighting each other over things
that with the distance of time and space
ultimately haven't really mattered that
much I think most people wouldn't expect
that a children's book would address the
climate crisis or global conflict I
would firstly say to that why not we
make a mistake as a society if we just
try to
protect and idolize our children because
we're not preparing them for the word at
large a lot of times parents are not
willing to have conversations that they
themselves are not comfortable with and
I think if it's done in a healthy enough
way
it's children are a lot more
intuitive Adept and observant then
they're often given credit for what did
your son Harlan think when you first
read the book to him uh he just keeps
looking to see if it's him in the book
jeffer's work goes beyond the page and
includes some unexpected collaborations
yeah I've worked with you two a fair bit
Bono and I met in a bar and we kind of
liked each other and that's a sentence
everyone dreams of saying bottle and I
met in a bar and we kind of liked each
other yeah yeah we got along and we got
talking and he invited me part of a
workshop for his charity one and at that
point they were thinking about making a
music video for Ordinary Love and so he
got me to do that too and then that led
on to other projects I did all the art
for the last tour on the on the big
screen I became like a collaborator with
them rather than a gun for hire which
always felt like a nice a very healthy
relationship but his magical mind seems
to always find its way back to picture
books when you get in the flow it's
about one of the most
joyous moments I'll crack myself up
sometimes the show my own then you
forget that it goes out and has a life
on its own and it's not up to me what
people think about it and I said
millions of children's bedrooms yeah
that's that's a wild thought no I'm not
going to think about that that's I'm
just going to keep making the next one
Jeffers current book meanwhile back on
Earth is on sale now Time Magazine
describes it as a dose of reality a dash
of Whimsy and we have another very
important two-year-old critic my son oh
loves the book gives it raise for you
yes we've read it quite a few times I
think and this is one of the first times
we we read it but he said I'm going to
space I'm going to space yeah it's a
great book and donating the mind yeah
kids are fans right yes they are I was
gonna say shout out to books or magic
where you shot that it's a fantastic
bookstore in in Brooklyn which has a lot
of fantastic bookstores but that's
particularly special one uh my kiddos
all four of them have been read Oliver
Jeffers and I gotta say the the winner
is not the big Ideas one but actually
stuck which is a story about a boy whose
kite gets stuck in a tree and then the
boy throws up everything in the
neighborhood up to it including like
cars trucks a whale and everything gets
stuck
and then he falls asleep and leaves it
all there it's a great story he's such a
talented guy and I as his mind was just
spinning I said does your mind ever stop
and he said no my wife says we have to
go in three week vacations because it
takes two weeks for my mind to just
pause
great guy thank you thank you so much